also offensichtlich ist opposition mist
und offensichtlich ist so weiter
regieren misst gibt es etwas drittes
nein ich spiele grundsätzlich an hans zu
große koalition kann kein dauerhafter
beitrag sein um demokratie zu festigen
wir sehen das auch in anderen
europäischen ländern dass dann länder
stärker werden insoweit müssen wir
natürlich anstreben dass diese große
koalition eine arbeit auf zeit
miteinander macht aber mir wird jetzt
durch zu viel über parteitaktik geredet
ich gucken die welt und sehe gigantische
herausforderungen
ich möchte ein handlungsfähiges
deutschland mit einer handlungsfähigen
regierung ich gucke nach europa wir
stehen vor dem break sieht wir stehen
vor anderen herausforderungen da muss
eine neue finanzplanung gemacht werden
das sind die interessen deutschlands und
der beitrag deutschlands groß die
gefordert werden und die wir auch
fordern müssen und ich schaue in die
innenpolitik in der uckermark hat eine
reihe von punkten genannt
ich sehe dort auch eine wirklich eine
wirkliche herausforderung hinsichtlich
der wachsenden ungleichheiten unserer
gesellschaft guckt sich mal dort wo man
so etwas hat treiben lassen
schily wer hätte je gedacht dass dieses
land dass europa sich am nächsten ist
und so einer konstellation dass dieses
land in solche sozialen unruhen hinein
drei schauen sie jetzt in frankreich wie
schwierig die lage ist also wir müssen
einen weg finden das was die koalition
auch vereinbart hat nämlich
halbzeitbilanz und drüber reden wo
müssen wir neues zusätzliches anpacken
dass das ernst gemeint wird und dass man
ernsthaft miteinander redet über die
fragen die die zukunft der menschen in
deutschland das macht bestimmt genau das
machen wir jetzt und zwar mit einem
blick auf die cdu
weil nicht nur bei der spd
der eindruck entsteht dass man in einer
therapiegruppe ist offensichtlich ist
auch die cdu ziemlich nervös
es läuft nicht gut für die christen
union erst kommt ihr das cea panten
jetzt womöglich der koalitionspartner in
umfragen ist sie auf den hund gekommen
stabil unter 30 durchhalteparolen für
eine hochnervöse partei auf der
grundlage war ein parteivorsitzender
wechsel verhandelt marken
koalitionsvertrag 0
es wird keinen neuen koalitionsvertrag
auch keine neue verhandlungen geben
keine weitere sozialdemokratisierung
keine neuwahlen mit kraftstrotzenden
grünen bleibt die groko mal wieder
alternativlos ich bin dabei
alternativlos
das möchte die cdu chefin nicht sein
jetzt droht sie den genossen zurück bei
der grundrente haben wir gesagt wir
werden in das parlamentarische verfahren
erst einsteigen wenn klar ist dass diese
koalition fortgesetzt wird
so jahns die neue cdu spd führung
entschuldigung die neue spd führung hat
sich offensichtlich vorgenommen der cdu
ein bisschen mehr auf die nerven zu
gehen
wie nervös ist die 10 wir sind total
lassen in dieser frage und wir brauchen
auch gar keine sprachlichen feinheiten
da im papier der spd wir erwarten dass
die spd sehr klar sagt wo sie hin will
und da muss ich kurt beck völlig recht
geben es geht doch nicht darum wer wann
wo was jetzt in der spd wird dieses
ganze thema was ist mit der spd das
interessiert die menschen im moment
nicht mehr sondern sie wollen wissen was
ist mit diesem land menschen in der cdu
haben auch keinen bock mehr auf diese
koalition mit der spd
na klar wenn man sich doch ständig mit
sich selbst beschäftigt und immer wieder
in frage gestellt ob das
regierungshandeln denn jetzt eigentlich
das ist man sich vorstellt oder man sich
andere dinge wünscht dann leiden beide
darunter wir kommen aus dem bundesland
ist auch noch große koalition hat bei
uns ist in allen umfragen bestätigt die
cdu auf einem stabilen niveau und zwar
auf dem niveau der csu und auch die spd
ist im saarland noch eine volkspartei
weil wir zusammen regieren und zusammen
zu unseren erfolgen auch stehen
offensichtlich funktioniert das dann und
wenn herr beck ja eben sagt die spd muss
dafür sorgen dass ein paar dinge in
deutschland noch einmal in die richtige
richtung geschoben werden sozialer
werden
da muss man ja sagen sie halten ja
selbst in diesem papier das zur
abstimmung gestellt wird fest dass es in
18 punkten große erfolge gegeben hat im
koalitionsvertrag in etwa bei der brücke
teilzeit oder wenn man über das thema
gute kita gesetz redet oder über die
parität in der finanzierung der
krankenversicherung
dann sagen sie es gibt zwölf weitere
punkte da haben sie sogar noch mehr
erreicht als sie sich eigentlich
überhaupt vorgestellt haben
mit blick auf die unternehmer
nachunternehmer haftung rovers
-kolumnist oder eben auch die grundrente
über die bei ihrem diskutiert haben bei
fünf punkten sagen sie da geht noch mehr
steht also 30 zu 5 dann denke ich doch
mal kann man doch ganz zufrieden sein
aber interessanterweise hat die eine
gerät kann fragen warum selber
angekündigt diese berühmte
revisionsklausel also das checken der
erfolge oder dem stand der großen
koalition
nochmal für verhandlungen zu nutzen das
war zwar schon im februar aber sie hat
gesagt wir haben darüber gesprochen wie
wir deutschland unter geänderten
rahmenbedingungen zukunftsfähig halten
können
dazu nutzen wir die revisionsklausel im
koalitionsvertrag und werden eigene
vorschläge vorlegen
was ist so schlimm an neuen
verhandlungen also dir sind jedenfalls
nicht die partei die im
koalitionsvertrag revisionsklausel
festzelt und dass dann der spd überlässt
natürlich diskutieren wir mit unserem
koalitionspartner darüber ob wir noch
auf dem richtigen weg sind und ich
glaube da ist es auch notwendig dass wir
neu denken und da hat frau kann man das
richtige gesagt wir brauchen jetzt
investitionen
wir brauchen eine fokussierung auf das
thema digitalisierung auf die
zukunftsthemen unserer wirtschaft geht
ist im moment nicht besonders gut mit
blick auf die stahlindustrie mit blick
auf die automobilindustrie
dann brauchen wir mehr innovationen und
darüber müssen wir reden und das geht
auch im koalition gedeckt vom
koalitionsvertrag noch wozu wir nicht
bereit sind ist dem koalitionsvertrag
neue aufzuschnüren nicht jedes mal wenn
neuer spd vorsitzender der spd
vorsitzende gewählt wird diskutiert mit
den koalitionsvertrag
wo kommen wir da hin wo kommen wir da
hin das ist interessant zu hören was
frau oppermann sagte man worüber soll
überhaupt verhandelt werden
und warum soll eigentlich die es die cdu
sorgen finden wir richtig wenn sie
nichts dafür kriegt also erstmal finde
ich es gut dass generell mehr offenheit
besteht auch noch mal ein gespräche zu
gehen
ich weiß dass die das ja auch im
saarland gemacht haben und auch nochmal
diskutiert haben und gemeinsam nochmal
vorhaben vereinbart haben in der großen
koalition von daher glaube ich ist das
auch ein gutes beispiel was man an der
stelle auch noch mal an führen kann
im übrigen muss ich aber noch eine sache
sagen zu diesem statement was annegret
kramp karrenbauer und tatsächlich auch
gebracht hat zum thema grundrente weil
ich also das wirklich das ist mir
wirklich zuwider dass sie wirklich die
einigung die es bei der grundrente gibt
die gemeinsam auch verkündet wurde dass
sie die jetzt für parteitaktische
spielchen ausnutzt und dass sie quasi
naja also politik auf dem rücken von 1 5
millionen menschen macht die irgendwie
das verdient haben die respekt
wir kriegen für ihre lebensleistung das
nicht also wirklich eine harte nummer
das für mich geht gar nicht das kann
dann müssen wir schon annegret kramer
aus können wir haben das gemeinsame wir
haben es wir haben es gemeinsam
vereinbart dass ganz parlamentarischen
verfahren gehen wenn die spd weiß ob sie
zu dieser koalition steht das ist doch
eine ganz natürliche sache und da muss
ich widersprechen die cdu steht zur
grundrente es geht darum lebensnah
endlich wird das gehirn nicht tragen und
wir in dem moment hat die grundrente und
stehen zum kompromiss aber es ist doch
eine selbstverständlichkeit dass dieser
kompromiss nur dann kommen kann wenn sie
auch weiter regieren wollen sonst gibt
es keine regel hat das statement zum
aufgefasst dass es eine drohung ist und
dass gesagt wird wir machen nur weiter
und das kommt wirklich nur wenn die spd
in der großen koalition zusammen
kurz noch mal konflikte zu hören koubek
hochinteressant im grunde haben beide
parteien den soli verhandelt die
grundrente unter schmerzen ausverhandelt
es gibt einen haushalt es gibt ein klima
paket warum sollte die cdu mit ihnen
noch einmal verhandeln na ja weil es
vereinbart ist miteinander zu reden es
vereinbart bilanz zu machen und
übernehmen die für die zukunft wichtig
sind neu zu reden tschuldigung
vereinbart also warum sollten wir reden
weil was vereinbart haben und
notwendigkeiten gibt sicher
unterschiedlich gewichtet von den beiden
koalitionspartnern aber es gibt diese
notwendigkeiten und darüber möchte ich
dass man vernünftig miteinander redet
und in der sache etwas bewegt ich bin
auch illusion frei wenn der regierung
auseinander fliegt dann wird man alte
projekte eben auch nicht einfach 11
fortschreiben
umso wichtiger ist es für uns finde ich
dass wir diese koalition fortsetzen
unter den genannten voraussetzungen weil
es um menschen geht es geht um leute die
beispielsweise 40 jahre als frisörin
gearbeitet haben und mit einer rente
heimgehen die 650 680 euro betragen und
die sollen jetzt 380 mehr kriegen das
ist mir ein anliegen und dafür zu
kämpfen
nun zu sagen das ist mehr als irgendein
parteienstreit das glaube ich lohnt sich
immer wieder in leons und dann sind wir
bei der frage worüber herr feldkirchen
soll verhandelt werden
12 euro mindestlohn nur noch
perspektivisch die 450 milliarden
investitionen stehen auch nicht mehr in
dem leitantrag da steht auch nicht mehr
drin dass die schwarze null geschleift
werden soll
worüber wird verhandelt und wie lange 12
euro mindestlohn ist jetzt nach hartem
kampf der revolutionäre der
vermeintlichen wieder reingekommen auch
dass man ein milliardenschweres
investitionsprogramm machen muss und
dann bleibt ja auch noch das ziel beim
klima mehr zu erreichen man legt sich
nicht auf zahlen fest also zum beispiel
diesen völlig irrsinnigen co2 bepreisung
von zehn euro pro tonne co2
den will fresken ich weiß nicht ob auch
herr walter borjans offenbar anheben
wäre dringend notwendig gewesen aber die
frage die sie eben gestellt hatten
warum muss man noch mal über etwas reden
was man kurz zuvor erst beschlossen
hatte
die ist natürlich gerade beim klima
paket absolut berechtigt ich meine diese
verabschiedung liegt ein paar wochen her
wenn man damals einen solchen murks
gemacht hat warum hat man es denn damals
nicht schon richtig gemacht warum muss
dann eine neue parteiführung kommen nach
drei wochen und sagen so lasst uns mal
ein richtiges klima manke das ist absurd
und zeigt auch dass diese ganze
revisionsklausel von anfang an mit
verlaub nicht wirklich ernst gemeint
nicht treiben nicht ernst gemeint war
sie wurde erfunden von der damaligen spd
führung um ein weiteres argument bei der
mitgliederabstimmung über ein neues
zustandekommen der großen koalition zu
haben so nach dem motto hier geben wir
euch eine möglichkeit zur halbzeit auch
die notbremse zu ziehen
das wurde so damals verkauft es war aber
nie so gemeint
so und jetzt kann ich schon
frau kramp karrenbauer verstehen und wie
sie sie wollte das auch nur in dem
moment nutzen wo sie dachte die cdu muss
ich mal wieder profitieren da kamen auch
sie auf die revisionsklausel beim neuen
spd führungsduo die berufen sich jetzt
auch darauf meiner meinung nach sind das
alles spielchen die einfach nur zeigen
dass diese koalition eigentlich ihren
zenit überschritten hat in dem sinne
dass beide parteien wahnsinnig drunter
leiden und beide parteien wirklich
drunter leiden frau oppermann die frage
12 euro mindestlohn hatte auch olaf
scholz schon gefordert
glauben sie denn dass norbert walter
borjans der bessere verhandlungspartner
wäre und dass olaf scholz also schlecht
verhandelt hat und dass er auch beim
klima paket schlecht verhandelt habe
würde das norbert walter borjans jetzt
besser machen das geht überhaupt gar
nicht darum jetzt irgendwie zu
entscheiden wer ist der bessere fahrer
hinter ihm fahrende frage ist noch mal
anders formuliert ganz einhalten wenn
man verhandeln wenn man keine roten
linien 1 führt und wie lange man
verhandelt weiß man auch nicht und man
ist dann eigentlich ein gutes ergebnis
da also erstens ich lese den leitantrag
so auch wenn ich mal an der einen oder
anderen stelle noch eine zuspitzung
vorstellen könnte aber ich ließ den so
dass da sehr klar drin steht wir wollen
nachschärfen beim thema klimaschutz weil
das einfach zu wenig ist und ich finde
auch da kann man noch mal ran gehen weil
niemand hat etwas davon wenn wir zwei
weitere jahre dieses thema verschlafen
sondern da muss gehandelt werden also
soll es um den co2 preis gehen es soll
darum gehen dass man für die
erneuerbaren energien
65 prozent fest schreibt das soll über
eine e auto quote verhandelt werden dass
sie stehen sehr detaillierte dinge drin
die den klimaschutz wirklich
voranbringen und das gleiche steht im
übrigen auch drin beim thema
investitionen dass man die 450
milliarden möchte dass man möchte dass
es in infrastruktur geht dass es zum
beispiel einen öffentlichen nahverkehr
geht in die schiene dass da wirklich was
gemacht werden muss und beim mindestlohn
steht genauso drin dass die zwölf euro
unser ziel sind das ist spd
beschlusslage dass es das wofür wir
stehen und da sollen schritte dahin
gemacht werden
und jetzt muss man gespräche führen und
man muss schauen kann man mit der union
was bewegen kriegen wir wirklich was
voran
ja aber können die union kann natürlich
auch vorschläge einbringen so ist dieser
revisionsklausel zu legen und
letztendlich entscheidet man dann und
zwar zeitnah auch darüber reicht uns das
so und dann sind wir aber ja genau bei
der frage also neben dem mal an du
kriegst den mindestlohn und dafür kriege
ich die unternehmenssteuerreform koch
oder dafür kriegst du ja insgesamt eben
eine steuerreform sind das nicht genau
diese art kompromisse der großen
koalition die den gegnern diese
regierung in der spd wie in der cdu zum
hals raus zwar muss man sagen dass
dieser diese klausel mit den
rahmenbedingungen ja als
rahmenbedingungen erst mal nicht
definiert dass sich die spd-parteispitze
ändern sondern dass sich ein land was
tut das ist ein konjunktureinbruch
beispielsweise gebe dass es also ein
neues umfeld gibt in dem neu verhandelt
werden muss unabhängig von von
personalien
ich kann mir ehrlicherweise nicht
vorstellen wenn man sich gerade beide
parteien anguckt die auf gar keinen fall
als die schuldigen r vom platz gehen
möchten die einen koalitionsbruch
hervorgerufen haben dass da nicht noch
spielraum ist man muss ja auch ein
koalitionsvertrag nicht neu verhandeln
man kann ja etwas ergänzen und herr beck
hat das eben völlig zurecht angesprochen
jetzt vielleicht betrifft weniger chile
aber sicherlich die die zukunft dieses
landes
da gibt es noch sehr viel zu tun und das
ist auch etwas was sicherlich in den in
den letzten jahren zu kurz gekommen ist
und wenn viele menschen in deutschland
angela merkel für ihre
flüchtlingspolitik kritisieren und ganz
klar sagen muss dass wir in einer
ausnahme situation in einem humanitären
motiven monetären notlage wo
entscheidung getroffen werden müssen
entscheidung schnell getroffen werden
müssen
da kann man jetzt mit messern hinterher
ist man immer schlauer aber bei einer
bundeskanzlerin dieser 2005 in der
regierung ist und wir immer noch davon
reden dass wir digitalisierung
vorantreiben müssen frage ich mich was
ist denn seit 2005 passiert es wurde
zuletzt an digital rat gegründet sie
können wir bestimmt sagen ob er wirklich
nur so sehr im geheimen
takt dass man überhaupt nicht mitbekommt
was er denn an erkenntnissen
hervorbringt also diese dieser dieser
aufbruch der eigentlich notwendig wäre
der fehlte ja schon von beginn an in der
großen koalition
auf der anderen seite hatte die spd
damals so viel staatspolitische
verantwortung dass sie werden die fdp
sich nicht in einer koalition getraut
hat weil das vertrauensverhältnis zu
angela merkel einfach nicht da war
die die spd sich hat in die pflicht
nehmen lassen und ich traue der cdu
wiederum auch soviel statt politische
verantwortung zu und im übrigen aus
sorge den schwarzen peter zu haben und
selber das aus zu verschulden
dass dann noch eine gewisse
geländegängigkeit also im übrigen
fordert sogar eine kleine freiheit hat
peer steinbrück r spricht wenn sogar der
chef des iw köln fordert dass es
durchaus investitionen geben sollte in
infrastruktur die frage ist immer nur
wofür diese investition nicht dran hält
cdu auch interessant dabei bin also da
ist ja nicht nur die wissenschaft
herbeck was passiert wenn der parteitag
den antrag der spd linken annimmt aus
der großen koalition auszusteigen
naja dann wäre das natürlich eine
verpflichtung das ist nur an der
demokratischen partei so aber es wird
nicht so weit kommen da bin ich ganz
sicher
denn der leitantrag von dem die rede es
ist in den gremien einstimmig
beschlossen worden also überall die
sogenannten flügel hinweg deshalb da
wäre es schon wieder alle erwartungen
die man haben kann wenn jetzt der
leitantrag darunter gestimmt würde es
muss ja zuerst ein solcher antrag
abgelehnt werden dass ein alternativ
antrag die sagten der harten art dann an
dieser stelle angenommen sie hätten das
nicht für möglich
ich halte das für absolut
unwahrscheinlich
und dann drehen wir das spiel um und
sagen herr feldenkirchen könnte diese
situation jetzt für annegret kramp
karrenbauer ein grund sein zu sagen wir
sollten diese große koalition beenden
wir sollten über alternativen nachdenken
ja ich glaube auch sie hätte das problem
wenn zu offenkundig ist dass das rein
taktisch motiviert wäre
dann würde es auch ihr und ihrer partei
schaden sollte es allerdings und das
finde ich eine sehr spannende analogie
zum jahr 2005 und zu angela merkel
sollte es zu einem vorzeitigen bruch
kommen weil man das gemeinsam beschließt
oder weil die spd nicht mehr möchte dann
würde sie tatsächlich glaube ich von
vorgezogenen neuwahlen profitieren weil
wir haben das ja kürzlich auf dem
leipziger parteitag gesehen
da gibt es eine riege von menschen die
sich die kanzlerkandidatur durchaus auch
zutrauen und eigentlich jetzt ein jahr
entspannt abwarten wollen wie dann die
dinge stehen ob frau kramp karrenbauer
immer noch so unbeliebt es in den
persönlichkeits werten und dann
vielleicht die chance bekommt genau in
dieser situation befand sich angela
merkel 2005 als gerhard schröder
überraschend vorzeitige neuwahlen
ausrief auch damals dabei gab es noch
den ominösen andenpakt die älteren
erinnern sich
da hatten sich die herren auch
verabredet im jahr 2006 als die wahlen
stattfinden sollten
doch noch mal die das recht auf die
kanzlerkandidatur von angela merkel
infrage zu stellen es ging dann so
hopplahopp da kamen die herren nicht
mehr hab ich mir dazu
und der rest ist bekannt so könnte es
eine historische situation für annegret
kramp karrenbauer sein dass die spd
gerade in dieser instabilität ist sie
tobias hans waren dabei als annegret
kramp karrenbauer schon mal schluss
gebracht hat
es gibt sie die furchtlose aa kk im jahr
2012 macht sie als ministerpräsidentin
kurzen prozess mit der jamaika koalition
im saarland ohne vorankündigung beendet
sie das erste schwarz-gelb-grüne bündnis
bundesweit aufgrund fdp interne querelen
und just zum dreikönigstreffen der
liberalen
die nunmehr seit monaten anhaltenden
zerwürfnisse innerhalb der fdp sah
stellen dieses notwendige fundament in
frage dass es sich aus meiner
persönlichen sicht und aus sicht der cdu
sei nicht mehr länger hinnehmbar ist
eine blaupause für das ende der groko
zerwürfnisse in der fdp waren das damals
die worte sind aber interessant könnte
es sein dass annegret kramp karrenbauer
einfach die spd rausschmeißt es war
damals eine ganz andere situation ist
nicht vergleichbar mit der heutigen
regierungskonstellation und ich will
dass man noch mal sagen wenn nicht so
etwas vorfällt was wirklich eine
zusammenarbeit nicht mehr möglich macht
dann haben die menschen in einem land
dann hat deutschland das recht auch bis
zum ende der legislaturperiode regieren
zu werden und deswegen sollten wir alles
daran setzen dass es damit jetzt auch
weiter geht und wenn man eben kümmern
gehört hat dann hat sich das nicht nach
koalitionsverhandlungen angeht sondern
eher schon nach sondierungsgesprächen
wir müssen mal gucken was dann
vielleicht noch möglich ist halt ich
glaube wir können uns das nicht leisten
wenn sie das was sie in ihrem antrag
schreiben umsetzen wollen sollten wir
schnell damit beginnen dafür zu sorgen
dass wir schnellere
genehmigungsverfahren haben in
deutschland dafür zu sorgen dass wir
wirklich auch zielgenau investieren
können denn das problem ist doch nicht
dass kein geld da ist das problem ist
dass wir das geld nicht abfließen lassen
können reden sie machen mit den
bürgermeisterinnen bürgermeistern mit
schulleiterinnen und schulleitern in
deutschland die wissen was das bedeutet
und ich will das will das noch mal sagen
sie sollten auch nicht der menschen
irgendwie vormachen es gibt jetzt neue
verhandlungen über das klimapaket wir
verhandeln gerade über das klimapaket im
vermittlungsausschuss des deutschen
bundestages da geht es genau darum wie
wir auf die opposition auch zu gehen an
dieser stelle wie wir auf die
bundesländer zu gehen die eben nicht
eur korrigiert sind deswegen ist das
doch genau das was wir jetzt machen
das sollten wir beherzt tun mit dem ziel
auch vor weihnachten was zu haben
grund soll es ebenfalls nicht so und
dann sind sie jetzt geschickt um diese
frage runde gegangen und ich stelle sie
trotzdem noch mal wenn die groko
zerbricht herr hand würde dieses land
dann ins chaos statt
wenn die coco zerbricht dann wird es
neuwahlen geben und die cdu ist zu jedem
zeitpunkt auch gerüstet für neuwahlen da
habe ich gar keine angst es wäre aber
nicht die beste lösung um die beste
lösung wäre dass wir jetzt miteinander
dieses projekt auch zu ende führen und
vielleicht etwas selbstbewusster sein
uns auch mal trauen zu unseren erfolgen
strittig märz kollege fordert die union
auf die sache alleine zu machen klar
der bundeshaushalt ist beschlossen eine
minderheitsregierung könnte im jahr 2020
regieren
ich war bereits 2017 der meinung dass
man dieses modell zumindest ausprobieren
kann als auch wenn angela merkel keine
freundin einer minderheitsregierung ist
könnt ihr sie trotzdem einführen
also herr merz war fraktionsvorsitzender
die regierungschef als ich
fraktionsvorsitzender war fand ich das
auch spannend eine minderheitsregierung
zu machen das finden alle parlamentarier
und die ganzen hole aber wenn sie
regierungschefin sind wissen sie das
ihren haushalt brauchen dann wissen sie
dass irgendwann auch ein neuer haushalt
ersetzt werden muss und dann müssen
sagen ja alles ein jahr ist er da und
dann ist er nicht mehr daran da müssen
sie sich den zusammensuchen und dann hat
das mit stabilität in deutschland nichts
zu tun
wir haben die eu ratspräsidentschaft vor
uns wo alle welt auch darauf schaut was
passiert in deutschland da möchte ich
nicht dass dieses land in der
minderheitsregierung sicherheitsrat
sondern es hat auch dass es hat eine
stabile regierungsmehrheit für das dann
doch mal die frage an kurt beck korrekt
müsste eine minderheitsregierung würde
eine minderheitsregierung automatisch
schlecht sein für dieses land
ich halte es für eine absolute
fehlentwicklung wenn wir die
stabilisierende lösung und ständig
miteinander diskutieren als wären die
ein teil unserer verfassungsvorgaben wir
haben in diesem jahr daran erinnert dass
vor 100 jahren die weimarer verfassung
auf den weg gebracht wurde
sie hatte einen große eine große
schwäche nämlich dass sie die mit
mehrheit eine regierung abwählen konnten
ohne eine neue zu wählen wir haben im
grundgesetz das vermieden durch das
konstruktive misstrauensvotum also der
regelfall ist ich muss wissen wer
regiert mit einer sauberen
parlamentarischen mehrheit dann wähle
ich einer bisherige regierung ab und
daran zu rütteln und zu spekulieren
könnte man nicht auch mal spiele machen
da oder dort das ist
demokratietheoretisch vielleicht ja ganz
spannend aber ich warne davor wo das hin
gehen wird wir haben dreimal solche
verfahren in deutschland schon gehabt
einmal von helmut kohl einmal die beiden
genannten fälle und das muss auf das
absolute minimum beschränkt werden
denn ich sehe ja innerhalb deutschlands
durchaus eine bedrohung unserer
demokratie
wir haben kräfte die weit außerhalb für
mich des spektrums der demokratie stehen
die 20 prozent und mehr an stimmen
kriegen und dann mit stabilitäts
elementen der verfassung unseres staates
zu spielen ja was ist nun sagt dass für
viele zuerst gehen jetzt sagt frau s
kinect dass diese große koalition mist
ist für die demokratie und dass sie eine
gefahr für die demokratie stehe aber
jetzt reden wir gifts war eben sie hat
politisch argumentiert ich teile ihre
meinung nicht aber sehr politisch
argumentiert und ich argumentiere jetzt
stand sie herrn festen und zu hört
nämlich verteidige die und 70 jahre
stabilität frieden und freiheit gebracht
haben und da würde ich mich immer
dagegen wäre da irgendwelche öffnenden
spiele oder sowas zu betreibt hatte in
die außenbezirke ein ganz ganz ganz
jenseits der theorie ich wundere mich
über die leichtigkeit mit der gerade
einfach ans gesagt hat dann wird es
neuwahlen geben wenn es im
koalitionspoker neuwagen in deutschland
sind eben auch nicht so leicht
erweiterbar und ich sehe auch noch nicht
die spd-fraktion die ja sagen wir kein
freund auch der der aktuellen lage ist
sich quasi selbst abschaffen weil
sicherlich viele viele parlamentarier
der spd bei neuwahlen nicht mehr in den
bundestag einziehen würden also wenn
eine vertrauensfrage gestellt wird ist
überhaupt nicht gesagt dass angela
merkel die mich doch noch mal gewinnt
auch werde nicht ohne risiken geheimer
wahl in fraktion stimmen der spd ganz
genauso
jetzt haben wir hier einen journalisten
kollegen der sagt die groko ist schlecht
für das land
was denken sie minderheitsregierung
neuwahlen also variante nummer eins die
spd minister raus friedrich merz und
seine freunde ein
warum soll das nicht da ich bin jetzt
total eingeschüchtert von ambac dass man
sich nicht diese frage stellt aber
sollte sag mal das neue führungsduo das
was es zum
angekündigt hat durch zehn jahre dann
würden die spd-minister aus dem kabinett
zurückgezogen
und dann steht die cdu vor der frage
trauen wir uns eine minderheitsregierung
zu hätte den vorteil 15 minister von cdu
und csu zu haben hat man auch nicht alle
tage hätte den nachteil dass angela
merkel dann nicht um ein minister
friedrich merz herumkommen ich glaube
das wollte sie vor ende ihrer karriere
unbedingt vermeiden würde aber noch
gehen sollte sie sich diese aufgabe dann
nicht zu trauen
ja dann gäbe es eben neuwahlen und das
ist nicht die katastrophe und dieses
ganze beschwören dieser koalition im
dienste der stabilität ist für mich
persönlich nicht überzeugend es gab mal
zwei das bundesrepublikanische
parteiensystem verankerte volksparteien
cdu und spd als sie 2005 zusammen ging
hatten sie 70 prozent heute sind sie bei
40 prozent die cdu die spd hat sich fast
um ein drittel zusammengeschrumpft ich
glaube das ist tatsächlich wer da den
systemischen zusammenhang nicht erkennt
dass das auch damit zusammenhängt dass
zwei volksparteien die sich tatsächlich
mal unterschieden haben durch den zwang
zusammenzuarbeiten profi losgeworden
sind dass kaum jemand mehr sagen kann
'die stehen im zweifel dafür und die
dafür das ist auch ein sehr sehr de
stabilisierendes element was aber
ehrlich gesagt sondern genau diese
gedankenspiele wirklich abschreckend
wenn sie sagen dann hätte die cdu/csu 15
ministern der bundesregierung sie sagen
dann würden so viele spd abgeordneten
ihr mandat verlieren
man darf da nicht immer die frage
stellen was für möglichkeiten bietet das
personell wir müssen noch die frage
stellen was ist mit dem land wäre und
diese frage stellen sich auf den
bürgerinnen und bürger sie wollen dass
das land regiert wird sie wollen dass
wir aufhören damit immer nur diese
fragen zu beantworten wer hat welchen
stadtteilen ist und das will solche
situation bewusst nicht künstlich herbei
führen
das steht im grundgesetz nicht es gibt
ein grundgesetz das deckt solche dinge
mit vielen umwegen vielleicht
ausnahmsweise aber im regelfall nicht
und da gibt es doch um bundespräsidenten
der das letzte
niemand wünscht niemand ja gut aber
bitte mit der zeit einiges los sein wird
einige praktische erwägungen die sich
aus der verfassung dieses landes einfach
ergeben und verstehen sie mich nicht
falsch ich wünsche mir keine
minderheitsregierung weil aus der noch
weniger impulse hervorgehen werden als
aus einer großen koalition aus cdu sicht
und insofern verstehe ich an märz ist
die aussicht darauf nächste nächstes
jahr zweiter halbjahr die
eu-ratspräsidentschaft dann wäre angela
merkel wieder kündigen von europa 15
minister zu stellen die sich noch
profilieren können dann wird es in
irgendeiner weise vorgezogene neuwahlen
dann mal geben aber vielleicht noch
nicht 2020 sondern früh 20 21 das ist
keiner das ist nicht nur eine
gedankenspielerei das krank schon so
passiert es mir nicht will dass das öl
so spielerisch sich zwei politiker gegen
diese idee frau oppermann wir fragen uns
nach der politischen alternative also
rot rot grün hat nicht mal eine
rechnerische mehrheit
warum sollen die grünen darauf warten
bis die spd bereit ist
es hat im moment keine rechnerische
mehrheit das ist richtig aber ich bin
ehrlich gesagt nicht so verzagt also
auch nicht so verzagt wie das hier
teilweise in dieser runde war ich glaube
dass man mit einem gemeinsamen projekt
auch ein rot rot grünes projekt aber
auch dass auch die spd wenn sie ihr
profil schärft und dafür ist der
parteitag jetzt erst der anfang so viele
tolle ideen die wird glaube ich wirklich
gut werden ich denke da zum beispiel
eine kindergrundsicherung ja kinderarmut
endlich abschaffen
ich denke auch nun die finanzpolitischen
instrumente vermögenssteuer endlich
wieder ein aber wir müssen jetzt endlich
reden kommen wir gehen das hier gibt es
würde uns machen genau was wir nicht nur
über diese gruppen die ganze zeit reden
sondern es gibt auch ein leben danach
und auch die spd und auch die cdu/csu
wird der nacht bestehen
ja mir geht es darum dass wir jetzt auch
wieder das profil schärfen und dann
glaube ich braucht man auch keine angst
davor haben in irgend eine debatte oder
auseinandersetzung zu gehen sondern dann
hat man wieder einen widerstreit von
ideen und das ist im grunde auch das was
mir langfristig wieder es gibt